[Music]
intense drama news I know these are like
a Serena submit by Fan Bingbing Bingbing
I love all the names you have to read it
tennis umpires are reportedly
considering a boycott on Serena
Williams's matches oh no that is
ridiculous I heard a little bit but I'll
let TIFF explain you tell me the umpire
or during one of their matches called
her like a thief or something like that
she called him oh she called him a thief
maybe you should tell her
see that's why I was like I'm gonna let
you explain it yeah so she was at the US
Open final the umpire issued three code
violations one for verbal abuse after
she called him a thief yeah that's what
it was all that I cost her a full game
so she lost to her opponent which is
that Japanese a black girl her name is
Osaka why was he a thief Osaka so um she
also got penalized so in one of those
three it included for a coaching
violation which she disputed like crazy
and I'm gonna show you a video clip of
her that's what started the whole thing
was is she like an appropriately dressed
or whatever - oh that's a different one
okay so this is her disputing the fact
that she because she got a coaching
violation which intent in tennis your
coach can't coach you while you're
playing
no one ever honors though ever I think
that is a rule but no one's ever been
called on so how do they do it like do
they like secret hand signal no it's
actually out in the open - though like
they're just on the sidelines and then
they like do whatever like baseball but
like know everything who gives a [ __ ]
well not only that but she was on the
other side and the coaches over here
like she couldn't even see her coach she
was like what are you talking she
thought he was doing a thumbs-up this is
very disputing it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and now grind early in his 39th year
working with the US Open his last year
as a referee is involved in something
were they doing the guiding probably
[Applause]
here yep yep
[Music]
you know what's crazy is she's like the
Tiger Woods of tennis like she's [ __ ]
huge that's why they're not gonna banner
that name is like you don't even have to
know tennis and you know that name Andre
Agassi and then the Williams sisters
that's it I don't know Andres that
European guy Andre Agassi actually even
spoke up and was like I side with Serena
I've said worth [ __ ] to these umpires
like I've done way worse and I've never
been called he was consider like the bad
boy of tennis right yeah cuz he's like a
rock star yeah yeah and so now like
umpires have gone to [ __ ] in a
backlash over all of this because oh
then going back to that the whole the
reason why she's wearing a tutu is
because after her after her having her
daughter she suffered a pulmonary
embolism which causes blood clots and
stuff and so she needed to wear this
tight cat suit in order to prevent blood
clotting oh man and so this is what she
wore in the French the French Open or I
forgot what it's called boobs and breath
and then they ended up banning her from
wearing this so in the protest way she
ended up wearing that too to over it no
she she got Nike and I think what's she
supposed to wear like us
just a regular tennis skirt yeah like
the tennis even though she has that
thing yeah what the hell even though
it's for her health and so she ended up
doing she had a collaboration between
Louie Vuitton and Virgil a below and
Nike yellow and they created this too to
look for her and then in order to do the
blood clot thing she's wearing
compression fishnet tights
isn't that the league's job before that
you step on court to say hey you can't
wear that versus you play a whole game I
don't like so what the hell yeah cuz
it's like you know like before every
like UFC boxing match you touch the
gloves I see all you have any weird oils
on you did you cut your nails for us in
powerlifting like they check all your
equipment and and like everything is
regulated but you're not a single if
that's gonna make you lift more weights
they touch the check all that like yet
NFL lets you play they they go out there
with like gold shoes and [ __ ] and then
just get fine later all for real and we
all the fans loved it we all just love
like all the different [ __ ] that they
come on and but the league is so lame
like this [ __ ] where it's a river
traditional old shitty rules to leave
the game of tennis
to look like this it's because tennis is
pretentious if you think about the type
of crowd and you know typically the type
of players and tennis is something that
is like old aristocratic [ __ ] versus
thank you yeah golf and stuff like that
versus basketball versus like
skateboarding or whatever you know so
they're gonna buy by different rules and
I think what's happening right now is
people try to maintain and preserve the
culture of what it is and they don't
like this new [ __ ] or whatever's but it
hasn't so I feel even more bad for
Sarina because ever since she came out
like she's been playing for like what 15
years 20 years like forever now um like
she's always like just stuck to her guns
and she's like this is who I am this is
how I was raised like I'm gonna put my
hair this way and she's always done it
but she's always gotten backlash from
them oh right the hair back laughs any
[ __ ] slab ain't [ __ ] happen at Tonya
Harding when she was in the skating so
ever since she started like I can see
what she's so frustrated right like like
most people might be like yo she
overreacted like back the [ __ ] up but
it's like you gotta consider she's like
been training she came back from having
baby like she's been going through this
[ __ ] ever since her career started
dealing with it all the time you hurting
of tennis without the scandal yes she's
like been top for a day forever so then
there's a really famous cartoonist he
created this cartoon over her meltdown
that the media is saying thank you this
dude [ __ ] the media this is an
Australian guy oh my god well he look
like a [ __ ] no that's like like what
do you call it like a totem pole
everyone oh yeah super racist because it
has like even her opponent who is
Japanese and black by the way is a
blonde girl what the [ __ ]
yeah oh that's supposed to be on soccer
yeah yeah she does even look like that
though this is like a really really
that's what everyone's saying is just
super racism it's just awful depiction
in general yeah cuz she didn't have a
meltdown like that we just saw no she
was being very reasonable very classy I
felt bad for her like I know I didn't
her like you know when people have a
meltdown they're annoying even if
they're right it was like when we're
playing off and you were super sad
because you're I felt that yeah that's
exactly what it is man you guys will see
that episode no you're right and
everyone doesn't believe you are you
right Joe he was about everyone that he
called out no well you bet he was
innocent
yeah he called me and Nicky were called
me out too and I didn't even vote for
him I was right about you colluded about
me for both of you collude we didn't you
said we were bad guys
yeah you said we were bad guys did you
were bad to me hurt my feelings but yeah
you were trying to just really get
protected if it was just you to by the
way it would have been fine but then
when everybody jumped on board that's
when I was like oh my [ __ ] god I just
burnt I just dug my own grave me not me
I knew I knew you're in two of two of my
homies here that really know me I didn't
call you no no you guys have my back you
guys refuse to raise your hand everyone
else Halloween look for that October
thirty-first baby but anyways let's go
back to this contra dredging up all
these emotions for Joe so Sarina got
fined $17,000 because of all that
that's nothing burden it is it's still
I'm with you I'm just saying good for
her because she's like she made like 2
million areally and all this thing
that's [ __ ] up
that is what though yeah and also
affects a cartoonist thing the newspaper
that they this went up they were
defending him and they were saying like
yeah you know the world has gone
officially mad when a celebrated
cartoonist is condemned by social media
hordes for depicting a famous sports
even his Australian Ruby Rose she posted
about it was like [ __ ] this guy not in
those terms because she's more PC but
she was just like I don't stand by this
guy I'm very ashamed he's despicable I
don't I don't condone this at all I'm
sorry my fellow Australians have to go
through this [ __ ] this guy's not right
even if he's like a super celebrated guy
like the idea that he only gets it right
is stupid like you could be a super
celebrated kick-ass cartoonist but then
you do a shitty cartoon yeah
and it's like you did a shitty cartoon
deal with it that's true that was super
racist look I mean he could have just
lived in a [ __ ] bubble too and he
lost touch with society for the last 30
years and then he [ __ ] did something
stupid like that
and it's like doesn't make it okay if
he's a legend or whatever you to yeah
then the whole blonde ponytail that they
were defending it to and they were like
because she actually has a blonde
ponytail what sucks is it overshadows
her win though because I actually knew
about her years ago when I went to Japan
I was watching this show and then I was
a bunch of comedians trying to play like
tennis with the all-star I was like oh
[ __ ] this is dope like she's she's
mixed-race Japanese celebrated in Japan
she you know and then it's it's it's
pretty awesome that she's kind of like
popular out there and she comes out and
then when she wins like if you saw the
speech all she can say is like I love
you too Serena right and it was such a
graceful win but all of that got
overshadowed from all of this [ __ ]
it wasn't a real win though yes it was
win by disqualification because of
Serena's
but it was the worst we hope yeah it's
arena win and then they took it from her
no they just because you must finish the
game right yeah so for her it would be
satisfying
when she won though what she liked
because when during a victory speech
there like how do you feel about this
she goes um I love you Serena and then
and then basically like at the point I'm
trying to make is she was inspired by so
yeah to kind of go out and become a
player right and how awesome is it to
actually be there on stage with or one
day and compete with her regardless if
you win or lose right story but that
story got taken alive such little class
I'm so competitive that even if I won by
like mean-spirited disqualification you
would celebrate
I'd grown up into this dance and like
get carried by the people and [ __ ] then
[ __ ] especially if you're losing it was
like what by 2001 damn straight that's
what you wanted all those hints in black
magic like we were like no we got it
wind of another coming soon JK party
video watch chicken party goes let's try
the pong it okay yeah we try play it
[Music]
you